-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"weirdest Halloween ever"
stories from you guys.
This first one is from
@RealAmyJo.
She says, "We rang the bell at
a house, and the guy was drunk.
He had no idea it was Halloween.
So he just gave us each a dollar
and then turned off
his porch light."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Am I a pretty emoji?"
[ Light laughter ]
This one's from @cam31.
He says, "Once at the mall,
I saw five people
walk into a public restroom
dressed as Clark Kent.
Five minutes later,
all five of them came out
dressed as Superman."
-Yeah.
-Wow, they really planned it.
"Look, it's five birds!
No.
They could be five drones."
[ Laughter ]
Just update.
-Yeah, update.
Just trying to make it modern.
"I'm gonna call an Uber."
You're making it modern.
-Yeah, making Superman modern.
-This one's from @NatalieWild7.
She says, "My friend and I were
walking through a haunted house
when a clown jumped out.
My friend freaked out and
screamed, 'Not today, biatch,'
and then ran away."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Why go?
-Stay in your lane, clown.
[ Laughter ]
-Unh-unh!
-This one's from @GumGummerson.
-Oh!
Ol' Gum Gummerson!
-Old Gum Gummerson.
-I've been here many years.
I got my prospectin' pan.
-Old Gum Gummerson.
Man, get out of here, you --
-Dagnabbit!
What's Gum say?
-Gum says, "A trick-or-treater
once showed up at my door
in a poncho that had the name
John written on it.
When we asked what he was,
he replied, 'I'm John.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Good costume.
-Yeah.
-Then Gum gave him some gum.
-This one's from @MissLoriT.
Oh, @MrsLoriT.
-Oh, Mrs.
-Maybe she's married to Mr. T.
-Oh.
-She says --
-I pity the fool.
-What's that?
[ Laughter ]
Who's married to Mr. T.
-The idea was that Superman
used to say, "It's a bird."
-"It's a plane.
It's Superman."
He didn't say it.
The people would say that.
-No, humans walking around
Metropolis.
-Right, would go, "Oh, my gosh,
it's a bird, it's a plane,
it's Superman.
-Oh, it's a plane.
No, it's Superman."
-Now you're saying,
"Is that a drone?"
-That's correct, or is that a --
some type of --
-Person.
-A flying --
A remote-control flying thing?
-Is that some sort
of a flying device?
-Maybe Balloon Boy?
And so people say, "Is that
a drone or Balloon Boy?"
No, by golly.
-It's just Superman.
-In fact, it's just Superman.
Yet again I was tricked.
-You fooled me once again.
[ Laughter ]
-Kryptoday and Kryptonite.
-Oh, my God.
Whaa! Shwack.
Trick or treat.
This one's from @PunkReckless.
-Yeah.
-She says, "I was dressed
as a fortune teller at a party.
A guy asked me to read his palm,
so I told him he'd get drunk
and have a good time.
He came back an hour later,
told me I was the real deal.
Then he fell over a table."
[ Laughter and applause ]
This last one
is from @MattLong1.
He says, "I once got so drunk
at a Halloween party
that when I got home,
I egged my own house."
There you have it, everybody.
Those are
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.